so I'm just gonna take a minute and show
you around the offices of Bruce Lee this
is Sydney
Kristina as you walk in you are greeted
by these long faces
since our emblem as you walk in this is
our poster wall with all the films of my
father and my brother and I've even got
one up there
Alex licensing Chris social-media store
content fabulousness the man who brings
down the hammer that's right we do have
a little gym here cuz it is Bruce Lee
and the archive we just sent over 500
items to Hong Kong we're opening in at
3-year exhibit at the Hong Kong Heritage
Museum July 19th so if you can be in
Hong Kong at any point over the next two
years go check it out but this is where
we keep all the writings the photographs
the books the memorabilia we're doing
stuff with the people at Raptor it's a
huge site people play video games and so
we're doing a partnership with Raptor
for the whole month of June I mean my
father has been washed in so many video
games and actually the video game space
is one that we are wanting to enter into
ourselves there been a number of reasons
why we haven't primarily that we didn't
have the rights to do so up until fairly
recently about a year ago and I think
the reason that you know we feel like
that would be successful for us is
because my dad is a martial artist
action person who's made these
phenomenal films video games are
action-packed it seems like a no-brainer
but you know we want to do it right we
want to do something that isn't
the legacy and super entertaining how
cool would it be to play Bruce Lee
either be him or you know be an
interaction with him in some way in a
universe that is of his making this is
the shoe that Kobe Bryant did and honor
my dad everybody loves the DJ tea which
is an awesome awesome shirt that our
licensee bone arrow makes I really love
the figures they're so well done you
know all of these more lifelike ones I
think they're really cool I find so much
value in his words in his actions in the
in the example of his life and so it's
very important to me and touching to me
that that still lives on and that people
of that age group are finding it are
finding relevance in it finding meaning
in it the whole reason that I do all of
this is because of that because I feel
that there's relevance and inspiration
to be had from his life and his words
and his deeds and if other people feel
that way especially young people who
have their whole lives ahead of them to
really shape their lives in a meaningful
way
it's amazing to me it's what it's all
about I don't really want my father to
be about nostalgia I want him to be
relevant the thing that is great and
beautiful about him is his message will
always be relevant so if we can apply
that to something contemporary then it's
it will continue to thrive there been
times when I've thought about actually
there's some projects we've been working
on that entail a young Bruce Lee where
where I thought about Harry Shum
I was a great young Bruce Lee because
obviously is a dancer so he can move
really well and and and even from a look
standpoint you know he's a good-looking
guy and and I think could could play him
well so I'd be perfectly yeah I think
about it yeah yeah yeah very good for it
yeah very because hope yeah me too I
would love I mean obviously all of the
like I love you dads aside and this is
your granddaughter and you know all that
stuff aside um I guess I would really
want to know what he thinks about this
you know and if he I think he would be
thrilled that his legacy has lasted so
long and he's become this person who's
thought of in so many wonderful positive
ways but I guess the question would be
is there anything that you would like to
see that you don't see now there's
anything that we that we forgot is there
anything that needs more attention I
would be really curious to know